maximilian janisch 16 jahre sein iq
liegt bei 149 plus das heißt er sprengt
die gängige skala maximilian
leidenschaft ist die mathematik bessere
ist ein spiel richtig gestern als ich am
stand war angefangen habe zu
programmieren das ist eine
visualisierung gespielt dass in der
klasse spielen wenn man sagen muss 1 2 3
und 4 500 mann ersetzt immer die zahlen
durch drei teilbar sind und die zahlen
den der diesmal spielfreien halten
durchbruch das spiel habe ich jetzt hier
eine sehr kleine version implementiert
mit einer sehr einfachen mit einem sehr
einfachen grafischen interface und das
verbessere ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen
ich habe auch ein bisschen was man
tickets mitgenommen aber gar nichts
machen für mehrere stunden ausstand ist
nicht meine
[Musik]
wie lebt es sich als höchst begabter
jugendlicher davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
orbetello in der südlichen toskana
hier verbringt maximilian seine
sommerferien
[Musik]
in dieser sprachschule elend maximilian
italienisch quasi ohne vorkenntnisse
angekommen belegte nach drei wochen
unterricht den fortgeschrittenenkurs
vorbereitungen für seine doktorarbeit
italiener und ich möchte bei ihm zu kurz
promovieren und es gibt eine neue
regelung bei der uni zürich
die sagt dass man nicht bei einer person
pro wir bei einfacher sondern dass man
zwei doktorvater krieg und mein plan ist
es dass ich vielleicht bei informieren
und als zweiter doktorvater seinen
doktorvater nähe sein
den louis d ambrosio und dass ich dann
also bei zwei dänischen profession
probieren würde und ich denke dann ist
es kein nachteil wenn das so ich dass
man dann endlich spricht unter anderen
sind auch einige studenten oder die
assistenten an der uni zürich italiener
und dann ist es keine nacht ein bisschen
maximilian grilliert wenn es um zahlen
spiele geht
und er hat sich bestens in seiner
temporären klasse integriert
[Applaus]
84 das hat es noch nie gegeben in der
geschichte unserer schule
er passt sich jeder situation an
das gefällt mir am besten er kann die
banalsten gespräche mit anderen
teenagern führen andererseits
beschäftigt er sich mit absolut
außergewöhnlichen und komplizierten
themen und das auf einem niveau das
andere jugendliche gar nicht
interessiert seine intelligenz
beschränkt sich nicht auf die mathematik
er hat einen viel breiteren horizont als
gleichaltrige
er weiß wirklich viel für sein alter es
ist schön sich mit ihm
auseinanderzusetzen
maximilian ist mit seinen 16 jahren der
jüngste student der schweiz
von all dem haben seine mitschüler in
der sprachschule erst beim erscheinen
der fernsehkamera erfahren
[Musik]
ich find's cool das ist er nicht so sein
komplettes leben so auf dieses ich bin
so gut in mathe ausrichtet sondern dass
er immer noch sich auch gerne für andere
sachen interessiert und die dann immer
noch gut fördert also ich habe mit ihm
zb sehr viel über programmieren und
kodierung von und hardware und hardware
schon das sind sonst die themen sowie
hardware und software ist schon ziemlich
ist schon ziemlich groß
zum beispiel robert also alles in
richtung computer science sagen wir so
in die richtung gehen automatisch das
ist vielleicht das fachgebiet wo wir
beide ein bisschen wissen es nicht
einfach und dann halt wirklich
begabungen wieder von maximilian inzell
bei entsprechende förderungen resultiert
daraus ein phänomen das fasziniert und
polarisiert
wir haben ein einziges gesetz steht 1
hier steht eins plus 6,1 cosinus von
putin ist kurios hockey der cosinus ist
bei 210 mit neun jahren kam maximilian
in die schlagzeilen weil er an der eth
studieren wollte
diese lehnte ab
hier cup beiden differenzieren mir gehen
sie mal funktionen meistens zeit im
internat auf welcher stufe wird das
unterrichtet gelehrt
das ist meines erachtens und zwar ist
dass die abschlussprüfung
das sollten sie miss von 2010 2014 ist
die letzte abschlussprüfung
das ist kein problem für dich die ich da
ich bis jetzt gerade nicht aber die von
elend schon da fühlen wir uns fast
veralbert und maximilian absolvierte die
primarschule in drei jahren mit neun hat
er die mathematik matura in der tasche
und als elfjähriger kamen in den genuss
eines auf ihn zugeschnittenen
förderprogramms an der universität
zürich
y
du hast genau diese sache von einer
seite und von der anderen seite die
begabung von maximilian ist
außergewöhnlich also ich habe mir früher
jemand gesehen der in diesem alter die
höhe der mathematik verstehen kann so
gut wie maximilian das ist eine ganz
große ausnahme
in meiner erfahrung
alle zwei wochen reiste maximilian
damals aus dem luzernischen meierskappel
nach zürich und schloss nebenbei das
gymnasium ab seit einem jahr ist
maximilian reguläre student an der
universität zürich und heute im dritten
semester seines mathematik studiums
seine mit studierenden generiert einen
vortrag hält sind schon zwei bis drei
jahre länger an der das spezielle hier
ist eben das im gymnasium war vor allem
für mich jetzt jemand fertig die mich
interessiert hat natürlich nicht nicht
so interessant
und das ist natürlich schön dass ich
jetzt hier spezielle manchmal nicht mehr
spezialisieren kann
und genau das mache was ich und was mich
interessiert was ist das schön der fall
maximilian bewegte die universität
zürich dazu das pilotprojekt
schülerstudium für besonders begabte
gymnasiastinnen und gymnasiasten zu
starten
maximilian förderung war anders gezielt
auf ihn zugeschnitten
dafür will er sich in diesen fällen bei
der universitätsleitung bedanken
parallel zu zürich studiert maximilian
auch in perpignan
dort konnte sich schon mit zwölf lammert
regulieren die uni zürich nahm ihn erst
letztes jahr aus regulären studenten auf
zu warten war die richtige entscheidung
sagt rektor michael henker
also ich denke ich mache jetzt meine
bachelor dieses projekts nächstes jahr
und macht dann weiter hier mit dem
master weiter und vielleicht mache ich
auch noch in papieren wo ich jetzt noch
ich wert bin auch mit dem sieger respekt
und er macht immer noch freude ja mir
ist wichtig dass sie die mathematische
begabung gefördert wird und da sind wir
sicher gestellt und standorte ist
genauso mit no dafür ihre hochschulreife
oder auch für eine gesellschaftliche
reife und die bucht in gottes namen halt
geben zu können sie nicht einfach ab
und sie schon manchmal sehr begabt in
größere richtig halte hatte normale sim
englisch sogar ein hochbegabter sozialer
stufe mehr schwierigkeiten als er in rom
hat sportlich und darum ist es ist
wichtig sich der maximilian loos im
system muss nimmt sondern dass man
nichts begleitet dort fördern wo man
kann aber durch dass sie die persönliche
entwicklung mit allen im umfeld wie wohl
er sich wohlfühlt wo unbekannte ist
zirka weiterentwickeln und den 17
mission accomplished
schon jetzt gibt es interessenten aus
der industrie die von maximilian
mathematischen fähigkeiten profitieren
möchten
so ist es zwar in zusammenarbeit
zwischen der lch einem kmu im bereich
entwicklung und bau von sondermaschinen
gekommen maximilian sonderprogramme zur
prozessoptimierung entwickeln
also mädels am meisten spaß machte
maximilian bösen übers haar bewege
und wenn es vielleicht andere motiviert
sondern sage du den du schon gar nicht
dass so uncool also die entspannende
auftrag die hände sehr interessante und
auch schwierige aufgabe
und wenn das auch messbar ist dass man
beispielsweise getankte wie satz von
maximilian henrich der energieverbrauch
von reproduktion können um 15 oder 20
prozent absenken
wenn man an diesem roboter gearbeitet
hat dann hat man eine so forte
visualisierung sagen sich seiner eigenen
arbeit man sieht sofort was hat es
geschafft mit meiner eigenen arbeit
das ist bei der mathe nicht direkt so
wenn man hat dort zum beispiel ein
abstraktes theorie und das ist nur
schwierig zu visualisieren und nur
wenige leute stehen das aber selbst hier
braucht man jetzt keinen sagen vorwissen
zum beispiel in robotik um zu verstehen
warum das cool ist nicht so und ja das
ist das ist natürlich der von so einer
sache wissenschaft oder angewandte
forschung seine langfristigen ziele
kennt maximilian noch nicht hauptsache
mathematik jetzt bin ich an der uni
zürich und ich bin auch noch andere und
ich habe ja und jetzt bin ich eben
zusätzlich noch hier
lc a beziehungsweise csu aber dass ich
finde das ist tatsächlich jetzt etwas
entspannt hat schon alles zum beispiel
am gymnasium ich kenne sachen machen die
mich wirklich gefallen
an die uni ziehen kein problem
zusammen mit seinem vater verfasste
maximilian vor vier jahren seine
autobiografie auf französisch und
deutsch
im zentrum der kampf der familie um eine
adäquate förderung maximilian die
hauptbotschaft des buches könnte man wie
folgt bezeichnen die besonderen talente
zb dem sport tanz in der musik werden
tatsächlich in der schweiz ausreichend
gefördert es gibt wenn ich das richtig
in erinnerung habe
23 sportgymnasien in der schweiz die
besonderen talente in den mint-fächern
mathematik informatik
naturwissenschaften und technik haben
diese möglichkeit nicht denn ich sie zu
verdanken
ländlich der burg im wm-rennen oder
schauspieler
das interessiert inschrift naja das
interessierte die möglichkeit den
selbstverständlichkeiten zwietracht
statiker fasnacht
geburtstags hat genügend kriege umgebung
sich gerade weithin fuchs alle
möglichkeiten hat man natürlich was wird
durch tröpfchen und und das angebots
machte aber das portal wagner und da
muss man das akzeptieren
deswegen kann man nicht für eine buch
promotionstour reiste maximilian vor
vier jahren mit seinem vater der noch
ihre erwachsene kinder aus erster ehe
hat nach paris
jetzt aber los nach nicht
da habe ich aus
das habe ich nicht nötig das liest du ja
das kann man sagen
was findest du so tollen ausblick tief
in den text von schuld und ich denke ich
habe mir gedacht du liest so die dicken
schinken irgendwelche romane
natürlich sehe ich habe ja noch vier
andere kind soll es ich denke aber diese
vaterschaft unterscheidet sich
fundamental von den anderen zunächst
unterscheidet sich ich sage mal der
mainzer der gesellschaft das was wir
jetzt machen wäre damals als
abscheuliche abscheuliches elitäres
gehabe klassifiziert worden
das war gar nicht möglich zu einer
schule zu kommen sagen der bursche
langweilt sich da einfach nicht die
klasse überspringen
das war gar nicht möglich aber ich hatte
auch eine frau die gegen das
leistungsprinzip war wie alt er ist mehr
darauf achtete dass es für die
jugendlichen und früher für die kinder
wirklich ein leben mit vielen
glücksmomenten ist selbst geht anders
das heißt dass die sind anders sie waren
sie auch ein leben mit vielen größen das
glück am meisten wenn man mit aller
kraft die man zur verfügung hat
zusammen ergebnis gekommen ist der
augenblick der völligen erschöpfung
das ist wichtig denke das ist für
maximilian auch so ja das denke ich ja
[Musik]
während seines sprach aufenthaltes in
orbetello lebt maximilian bei einer
gastfamilie seine temporären eltern sind
voll des lobes über den
außergewöhnlichen jugendlichen aus der
schweiz
[Musik]
was schön ist er hört zu
normalerweise ist es nicht so dass ein
jugendlicher einem erwachsenen zuhört
aber er hört zu
er beobachtet er prägt sich alles ein
das ist gut
er ist aber kein besserwisser er weiß
viel weiter zu hören
maximilian ist ein junge wie alle mitte
haben möchten
er ist gut erzogen intelligent anständig
und er ist genau genau heißt erhält in
seinem zimmer perfekt ordnung
keiner der anderen jungs ich habe den
ganzen sommer über jungs aus der
sprachschule hier aber ich möchte ich
immer hier haben ich habe sehr gute
noten gekriegt das freut mich natürlich
dass nur braun ist er nicht geworden
[Musik]
die
seit maximilian einem griffel in der
hand halten kann
treffen sich vater und sohn zur
täglichen stunde mathe für maximilian
ein kleiner dämpfer wort dass maximilian
auf seinen bachelor noch ein jahr warten
muss wegen einer krankheit sauber zu
spät eingereichten arbeit heute
diskutieren vater und sohn mögliche
themen für die masterarbeit
so jetzt herr kandidaten wir mehrere
vorschläge geben die errichtung neuer
gleichen gehen und habe nicht sicher was
ich nehme aber okay ich fange dann mal
mit der masterarbeit brauche dann für
den master vermutlich regulär drei
semester ungefähr und machte dann weiter
mit der promotion und kann dann
möglicherweise meine promotion in
princeton abschließen und ich fange eine
zürich und macht man vielleicht einen
gang zurück und die letzten beiden jahre
in princeton
das ist so der provisorische zukunft
fahren aber es kann sich noch viel
ändern
und dann hat man hier die natürliche
produktion auf die bahn thomas tree
schießt mathematik professor im
ruhestand und fördere seines
hochbegabten sohnes dass diese rollen
könnten allerdings schon bald umgekehrt
sein
er hat mich überflügelt also was ich
beitragen kann ist der tatbestand das
ist eine breite mathematische ausbildung
hardware weiß ich weiß viel mehr war
das kann ich dann auch wieder geben und
zwar auch so so so wiedergeben dass es
viel verständlicher ist also in einem
lehrbuch ist das letztendlich besser
machen aber jetzt zum beispiel diese
masterarbeit die dazu notwendigen
speziellen technischen verfahren der
mathematik die baut der kathedralen aber
dazu gibt es auch maschinen diese
kathedralen geistigen kapitalen der band
die die kenne ich nicht und ich habe ich
schwere zweifel ob ich noch die kraft zu
erlernen
im dem sinne ist ist mir schon vor wie
das leben noch was beibringen können
jeden tag sehr viel zu werden also ich
denke da besteht keine gefahr
[Musik]
die
maximilian sprachaufenthalte neigt sich
dem ende zu
in der letzten woche sind seine eltern
angereist um einige tage zusammen mit
ihrem sohn in der toskana zu verbringen
und ihn anschließend mit zurück in die
schweiz zu nehmen
also wir sind jetzt hier in an sidonia
ein kleiner ort nicht weit entfernt von
svenja haack wenn jetzt eine der großen
ausgrabungsstätte was etrusker betrifft
russische grabfelder kirchenbesuche
zusammen mit den eltern so die meisten
anderen 16 jährigen würden bei einem
solchen ferienprogramm wahrscheinlich
reißaus nehmen was in deinem buch aus
dem noch jungen jahres geschrieben dass
durch die pubertät wahrscheinlich
einfach auslässt machst du das also ich
denke die prognose war richten
das ist einfach so dafür kann ich nicht
viel sagen ich habe keine
schwierigkeiten mehr anders als es von
vielen vorausgesagt wurde habe ich
wirklich moment keine große
schwierigkeiten
das ist immer die frage wie man guckte
definiert hormonschwankungen
freudlosigkeit lustlosigkeit
launenhaftigkeit weil man das
hinlänglich unter pubertät besteht der
rebellion gegen die eltern aber bekommt
schon dem gar nichts mit gar nicht ich
habe einen sehr sehr charmant den
umgänglichen lebens würdigen so der mich
auf augenhöhe behandelt und mich ernst
nimmt und umgekehrt
und ich habe mich wirklich nach wie vor
wie immer eine große freude an ihm haben
ich bin da ist ein pflegeleichter so aus
neunjährige hatte maximilian seine
eltern aus seiner besten freunde
bezeichnet also meine beziehung immer
noch sehr eng
ich war vielleicht etwas unvorsichtig
mit der bezeichnung damals weil wenn ich
sage meine eltern sind meine besten
freunde suggeriert dass dass ich keine
freunde habe aber das ist natürlich
nicht der fall
ich sage so meine beziehung zu meinen
eltern ist etwas eigentlich vermeiden
jetzt bewusst
die bezeichnung besten freund aber meine
beziehung immer noch formidabel also da
kann ich bin nicht geschehen maximilian
und seine eltern ein eingeschworenes
team
alle drei kümmern sich wenig darum was
andere von ihnen denken angstfreiheit
das hätten ihm seine eltern mit auf den
weg gegeben sagt maximilian
in gewisser weise haben sie mich so
erzogen dass ich mir gleich eine
gesellschaft dass ich keine angst hat
von der norm abzuweichen dass ich keine
angst hab irgendwie was spezielles zu
machen mit 16 an die uni zu gehen also
das ist für mich kam das nicht auch
angst vor der angst von normen und ich
hoffe auch dass ich zum beispiel durch
diesen film diesen leuten ein wenig die
angst nehmen kann dass ich das etwas
realisieren kann dass ich sagen kann
das kann erfolg haben also dass ich da
auch anderen leuten die achsen wie das
ist hier dass das c
[Musik]